[Music]
[Music]
it has begun we have a absolutely packed
show the trade deadline breaking down
everything that happened there some news
and notes around the NFL Sims got to
some film he has a story that he didn't
tell me and I'm gonna kill me he can't
tell you guys yet it's not vetted sorry
can't tell you though how are you guys
I'm just gonna let this go if this is
three hours I'm good with that
don't worry let's talk about Sun is
gonna be Thanos daughter is gonna be a
farmer right do you get dressed up while
they go around I mean like two years ago
I think I put like a skeleton t-shirt on
do they use pillowcases anymore you know
or are there like special custom
Halloween bags they like with side
pockets for your cell phone they
actually like like yeah like the plastic
like in jar dupit things right there was
nothing better than taking a pillowcase
off the pillow and throwing over your
back like freaking John yes I see we are
not like our kids are healthy but I
don't like oh you can't eat candy you
know you can't like we have snacks in
the house and they're allowed to eat
them and yeah or if I come over there's
candy right it was so they're not like
deprived of that so it's actually funny
were the last two years when I was out
with them like they got candy in there
let's go I'm good and I was like well
that's it's all you want like just the
one little lantern warts of can I
literally went on a rant last night when
it when I was a child we'd play
kick-the-can
flashlight tag and I was like looking at
my phone I was like I would never go
outside if I was a kid and then my wife
buys so much candy that's the other
reason they don't care like we have the
best candy at home already so what do
they care unless you get the same types
every year uh yes I do not do
trick-or-treat cuz no kids coming up to
a fifth floor walk-up apartment in New
York City if they did I would give them
a remote control I guess
$20 if they do yeah like I would I would
hey didn't we've got money last week on
the game we did oh is that game though I
don't remember good spirits today candy
candy I'm gonna browse yeah yeah I'll be
giving out Reese's Cups and snicker yeah
Daniel gets king-size Reese's Kit Kats
blow pops spree that's free sweet tarts
and we know that your dad gives out my
dad's ridiculous it's ridiculous
I bet you my dad spends $10,000 on
Halloween candy yeah what's going on
joking I'm not even joking like he
doesn't make sense you know if you saw
the crowd that it will be at his house
tonight
he might have 10,000 people they can
teach your dad how to do Instagram
stories I mean maybe I just had to teach
Josh how to teach me how to add somebody
yesterday to teach my family how to add
somebody cuz you know my dad and brother
are doing this quarterback thing right
yes and he told me they weren't putting
the period in front of the at and they
were starting the tweet with the admin
she so I know one season I texted my
brother it's like he he laughed he's
like Oh any other great comedy is like a
Sims in the social media not our strong
point not our strong one
speaking of social media if you're
questioning whether that's us in the
YouTube comments the Sims and left go
account that is us we are questioning
people think it might be fake I don't
know it's not fake it's real if you
haven't checked out the Simpson Lefko
show yet on YouTube please do you will
see me pranking the crap out of Chris
Sims worked out
we got a fake news alert we had a fake
pro football talk page saying all in on
that Odell Beckham jr. was traded to the
Texans after as soon as you said that on
on the the podcast that came out Tuesday
yeah I texted the producers I said let's
get him go to the time we were gonna do
the Panthers and then I was sitting in
the control room during the podcast I
said the Panthers he asked you if the
Panthers made sense and we're like no
and I was like guys we can't do the
Panthers but he says the Texans could
happen yeah I mean but the more
impressive thing is they knew I was like
red yes well when you have an alert on
your phone
and then they pull up a website Pro
Football Talk with it on top of there
and then you clicked on it yeah there
was an article that's a new level crap
okay yeah I won't you know what you're
right to that point you not knowing the
internet enough not even thinking that
Photoshop could be a thing yes
yeah like McManus just went in there and
change the code downloaded the HTML
and he recoded the page and then saved
what it looked he put one on today when
I was down there in that area and said
Chris Simms signs with the bills I love
it
I said dude you need to send me that so
I can send it to my brother cuz he'll
have like a [ __ ] heart attack okay
what the [ __ ] decide you not me one
other one other update we are having
people saying whatever happened to the F
the play up stuff I know I think people
watch the first game or like man it's
gonna take a lot of work but if you have
stats send them to us cuz we'll talk
about it are there anyone that sticks
out to you right away that man they've
really been F in the play up this year I
don't know I just read that Marcus
Davenport's gonna miss a few yes a toe
injury I've been locked in the cave so I
always forget that you don't get alerts
I haven't yeah and then when I watch
film I just shut it all out for a little
while but and literate literally is
there a week that couldn't be worse for
him to get a toe injury than when
they're playing the rams yeah absolutely
need a pass Russia stinks and he's
really been starting to like a merge
like real-deal merge like that's where
it's disappointing damn yeah a month
toe toe it seems so pointless off but
yet it's the worst worse than a high
ankle sprain hmm it's equally as
annoying ah this toe is really can be
really paying me really isn't the
follow-up question which toe it's good
it's gonna be the big toe I would think
most more times than not it's the big
toe little toe toe it's gone right to
the big toe it's the worst though I mean
I would argue that if you hurt that
fourth toe it's tough because I can't
bend my fourth toe without bending my
pinky toe you know what I mean those are
connected somehow explain that to me why
are those two toes connected what do you
say big feet let's say that here like I
moved my pinky I don't have to do that
why do you have like an independent
contractor well double jente
double-jointed fingers yes I do do that
big toe why does it suck it's just you
know you don't realize that it's first
of all you're in a cleat okay cleats are
not exactly like lino LeBron James as
far as comfort is concerned yeah it's a
little hard and yeah you're living is
digging your cleats into the ground and
pushing your 275 pound body to be
extremely explosive and then
jamming that cleat in the ground the
change of direction or doing without
whatever else I mean big toe injury and
dion candor dion sanders career for real
that was it that's why he had a retired
the first time his toe had gotten so bad
at the end in dallas he couldn't play
anymore
wow yeah i want to say that i think that
when you say cleat it is my favorite
sound but at the same point i'm also
really worried about the microphone
getting too much spit on and cleat you
there's I'm telling you words that have
CL you add a CH right in the middle oh
wait that's incredible say it again no
no now he's gonna think about that no I
hear it there's a little you say can you
say crispy crunchy chicken crispy
crunchy chicken crispy crunchy chicken
that's hard now say cluck-cluck-cluck I
love like you with the esses I I've been
adding s as [ __ ] yesterday we did 9
takes on the show and you had a test I
don't get it
alright one other thing is the other on
Monday you stole my running back
rankings and I almost said runnings
backs right there
you stole my running back rankings and
what was his top six it went yeah so
originally we were gonna do at our
behind we were gonna do a top five and
me and fentruck were texting yeah and we
were like man if there's any way that we
can get Komara on the camara on the
graphic yeah because we're tired we
really think that and it worked it did
that if you just put the number six guy
on the graphic people on the internet
don't get as upset because they just go
they look for who's not on the graphic
so your rankings were girly was once a
qualm was - creme hunt was three
Zeke Lee Gordon five Camaros five I was
like almost a tie at five right but what
he is is people aren't gonna argue we're
Camaros should be just shouldn't be on
but guess what people are upset at you
again of course they are and guess what
they're upset about not being in your
tops I mean I know cuz he showed me the
comment James Connor stats don't lie and
Ryan shazier even commented what a Ryan
she's seen Ryan shazier this is the
reason why and we're gonna have Jalen
Ramsey
as a guest in a little bit Jalen Ramsey
is like I know you guys and I go who's
watching our youtubes but really they're
seeing our Instagram stuff right because
we comment all the time about how great
Jalen Ramsey is but apparently Ryan
shazier has issues with your rings so he
just wrote do much disrespectful where J
see under the Instagram post on
everybody is saying where's James Connor
and I'm not gonna lie
kind of excited for you to crap on James
Connor right now well I'm not gonna crap
on him he's doing good things but at no
point am I gonna put him in this class
yet all right especially with you know
the limited sample size compared to the
other guys and I know after I said that
comment people are gonna go say Quan
Buckley hey listen everybody
James Connors not on the same planet is
say Quan Barkley okay Adrian Peterson
doesn't say the things he says about say
Quan Barkley last week say qualms
Barkley is one of the greatest specimens
to ever come into the sport of football
that's what we're talking about there so
get off that crap right now and don't
tell me stats don't lie okay they lie a
lot they I don't really give a damn
I mean Lorenzo Alexander was one of the
league's leaders and sacks a fusion guy
he was not the best pass rusher oh he's
such a good pass rusher that they made
him an inside linebacker in Buffalo oh
yeah that's what you did who was the
number one rated quarterback in
footballer Alex right exactly okay and a
discussion let's move on so my only
other thing though about James Connor is
if say Kwan's on that planet yeah what
planet is James Connor on James
he's on earth no but I mean what other
running backs are on his oh okay I mean
yeah there's you know again is he better
than Joe Mixon I know I don't think so
this is gonna be really funny I know
this isn't better than Aaron Jones yes
okay okay yes he's like better than
Dalvin cook right now I'm gonna give him
that yeah but okay but like oh how about
carrion Johnson he's been phenomenal
he says amazing stuff on a weekly basis
and he doesn't have Antonio Brown a Jew
juice Minister and the rest of the
Pittsburgh Steelers teams out there you
know okay there's just you know again
it's also say that you're in Peterson
the fifth best running back in the NFL
are you or do you guys really think that
like okay well the stats don't lie he is
guys he's five
oh no wolf the status Golub Lindsay how
about him he's in a discussion with
Connor we're gonna get to him well so
I'm just saying like
again it's not disrespect I do take in
overall yes Mike you you I'd like to
take guys who have a little bit more of
a sample size yes he is but he's doing
really good things and I'm not trying to
hate on him I just I'm just saying I
don't think he's in their class at this
time the thing you said about Adrian
Peterson talking about say Kwan I feel
is interesting because and we're gonna
get into this with Brady talking about
Rogers later yeah but if people don't
want to listen to analysts talk about
this yeah look at what the players are
saying about each other cuz they're on
the field with each other I may see it
exactly I mean what did coleus Campbell
say I mean clay is Campbell the first
game of the year was like man that guy's
cut from a different cloth yeah when I
hit him I felt it I'm also just gonna
throw this tastic out there he has 599
rushing yards yeah it's about 600 right
280 only one of the grounds or against
the brown so nearly half of his rushing
yards against the Browns and also I'm
not making a guy top-five if he rushes
for 36 yards combined against Kansas
City in Baltimore yeah because none of
those other running backs have had a
game like that
James Connor is really good the
offensive system that they're running
right now opens up and I would say the
best thing he does is catch the Ben
Roethlisberger check downs and make a
guy miss or two really good running back
right just not in this way I agree and
add to that point left go what you're
saying there which is spot-on about the
Browns one of the worst defenses in
football which is surprising because of
course I didn't expect that
yeah but they don't have a real quality
win the whole year who the Steelers
Browns Bret Browns ty Falcons Buccaneers
bangles I mean the bangles are
historically bad on defense they were
about to break the record I mean they're
on pace okay so you know again yes those
things are taken to it sound like a shot
at Pittsburgh as well well I think no I
think Pittsburgh now that they're for
and what for 2 & 1 they were the worst
team now and now all of a sudden they're
being overrated I see teams going
they're better than the Carolina
Panthers no they're not sorry they're
not Carolina's quality wins is played a
tougher schedule and everything that we
should adopt Carolina
our new podcast team because man that
Cam Newton video we just took a clip of
our podcast for Monday and put it out
and Panthers fans like yes
media people not [ __ ] on our team I
love you guys yep media people from
Carolina calling me to be on the radio
like in for you at Philly radio today I
was anything good uh you know just
talking go lucky perfect let's talk
trades there were five notable trades
yesterday there were some other ones too
but what I've done is I've ranked them
from five to one from least important to
most important go ahead captain schmuck
I'm ranking them because I don't know if
Sims is gonna agree
yeah and I'm tired of asking you to do
things so I'm just gonna do things
myself I like this this is good this
isn't old you this will lead to more
arguments I can't you know I can't do it
all I can't always be Jordan use other
times you gotta be you know you got to
be Pippen I'm gonna be honest before any
a cup of sucka you're the Steve Kerr
just knock down the big threes and we
need it all right
me and him this is Luc Longley and
Horace Grant getting the rebound number
five number five time on to Baltimore
Baltimore sends back a twenty twenty
seventh round pick I don't I don't want
to get into the conversation about how
the Packers had to do this I've heard it
everywhere and no [ __ ] move on right
Baltimore's perspective you did say they
needed a running back yes I don't know
if Montgomery's gonna be able to wear
the 88 but I'd also say he is that's
incredible is incredible but I'd also
say he joined Chavarria salen and Alex
Collins and I don't know if he's better
than those guys anyway
but it's another position list football
player for a team that he's a little bit
like Willie Snead is a look like they
just have now like seven or eight guys
that have no great characteristics but
do a little bit everything yeah yeah I
mean I think you're right they needed
the upgrade of the position like we
talked about I do I think it's a slight
a slight upgrade I'm not gonna take time
on covering over Alex Colin I do I think
he can make more out of less yes I do
yeah I do I think he's just a little bit
more of an explosive quicker athlete
maybe I'm wrong and we'll really be able
to tell once he gets in the unifier I'll
be able to see many people forget was a
first-round athlete right it fell to the
third round with off the field issues
it was a stun at Stanford yes he was
he's never been as
ugly as he was a Stanford he had ankle
foot issues I can't remember his last
year at Stanford and it really I feel
like he'd never quite got the
explosiveness back after that but I am
interested to see that and I do think
it's a slight upgrade for balton okay
yeah my number four trade trade deadline
this might surprise you I'm going Dante
Fowler to the Ramo oh it does surprise
me okay
disagree disagree disagree nice so it is
going to be a third-round pick in the
upcoming draft and a fifth round pick in
2020 which is goes against my ranking I
mean there's a lot of value for a guy
that really hasn't done anything
my third pick in the draft yeah the Rams
now has seven former first-round picks
on their defense the last three games I
checked out Dante Fowler snap counts
he's played 22 26 and 26 snaps seems
about right that sounds like what he's
gonna play with the Rams - maybe a
little bit more maybe in the 40s yeah
they're gonna really start he well I
think he will start for them he has two
sacks this year one in week two the
strip of Brady where he also recovered
the fumble which was big towards the end
of the game yeah and last week or the
week before last week against Houston
the reason I put it this low is I look
at this defensive line and I know what
its gonna allow them to do but I don't
I'm not gonna play this game where just
because he was a first-round pick four
or five years ago I'm automatically
saying he's going to be that guy yeah
he's had a lot of off the field issues
and I'm not even factoring that into it
right
I see Altair the first practice he ever
played in for Jacksonville I'm just
looking at it and going I don't know
what he is yeah I understand that and I
and the other guys that I'm gonna bring
up I know more of who they are but why
are you against me it's where would you
make this compared to the Hoglund dick
system arias Thomas's golden Tate's
where would you have I would probably
put it in front of the haha Clinton
dicks okay I know that for sure the
Demaryius one is debatable okay so yeah
I've met two three why is it more
important than I think I think he's
better than what you're giving him
credit for is he better than what they
have definitely yes he is it's the only
thing on their team that I look at go
they need that that's the only thing I
look at their roster and go you say that
what does
and edge rusher an edge [ __ ] the play up
guy so you know ten sex with Aaron
Donald right in the NFL right Tomic
ensues
you know Crocker's is good on the
anybody's a run stop it he's a defensive
tackle that they've put a gun right so
now you have a legitimate guy who could
come off the edge he's very good against
the run did the price is steep I did I
understand that I think though you know
they're in this for the long haul but I
I know that and we're gonna get to that
I mean more him the plate yeah I think
him though I know I'm gonna get there
but him the player is explosive it is he
causes more havoc even when I just
watched this Eagles game okay then then
you would realize like you know oh
Karsten had a move in the paço that was
Dante Fowler that pushed him back you
know Zach Ertz coming behind the line of
scrimmage trying to block him to run in
the inside zone where the tight end
kicks out the accident man Zach Ertz was
like the hell with that I ain't hitting
that guy my question with him is he
we're not in the situation where now
he's going to addy line with a lot of
alpha males and it's gonna wake him up
yeah the Jaguars traded him because they
were not gonna sign him because they
have so many studs in the defense yeah
they're not gonna for drafted a
first-round defense and and Haven Brian
but when he goes from a Jacksonville
defense yeah that energy right to a Rams
defensive line with those guys is it is
it comfortable for him I think it is
comfortable I think he's gonna like it I
would say the attitude is probably gonna
be very similar I mean that's what I
mean Wade Phillips I forget the
defensive line coach about the Rams but
you know he's a great guy who's got a
great way about him you know I think
scenery changed I think the fact that
yeah Yannick and Gok way has stolen his
thunder they're their know they know
they're gonna keep him he's the one
that's gonna get Dante Fowler's money
not your ill Johnson Bill Johnson Bill
Johnson is like one of the all-time cool
personalities and then I fell and I've
only crossed over them here and there
but I've been on practice fields and
watched him yellow that wasn't the guy
that was talking to you at Rams camp was
no that was not it was not but he's he's
he's your ultimate d line guy guys wanna
play for him and he gets the best out of
them and they go pedal of the metal
because of him yeah I think this is a
good thing for him and I do think it's a
good thing for the Rams
it is interesting especially when we
talked about Marcus
import' getting hurt you know pass
rushers are a premium they are at all
times yeah all right so you may have
convinced me I had Holland Dix third
yeah
Washington gave up a fourth round pick
in this year's draft by the way a lot of
these guys that are on short term deals
if they don't sign and get big money
elsewhere the team will get a
compensatory pick back now the thing is
and the reason a lot of these teams are
trading they want their pick now that
compensatory pick does not come until
2020 it isn't always happening and it
does not guarantee your compensatory
right you're not guaranteed it ah the
reason I had them third is I look at the
Washington defense and I see that
they're second rated and run and I see
that they're in the teens when it comes
to defending the pass yeah and I'm not
saying that haha Clinton dicks is
something special now PFF does haha
Clinton dicks is the third rated safety
on PFF and DJ swearin sure is the second
rated safety in PFF before we even get
into that how inaccurate / accurate is
that yeah too much is made and those
things like oh okay he got a positive on
this play oh he was the deep safety and
he backpedaled and did his job Plus got
a puss on that plane great I don't
really care it's about difference making
plays it's about you know what you're
being asked to do yes on a doubt so just
because you're not blowing your
assignment doesn't mean you're doing
great things on the football field the
reason is the three though is I think
that haha Clinton Dixon swear injure
their makeup makes a lot of sense
together
it's another Alabama guy on this defense
which is hilarious at this point that
read the entire Alabama Crimson Tide
right because I'm so offended by their
team I might just call them the
Washington Tide just because at this
point accurate and it's another piece
for minovsky sure where I looked at his
defense and went you know what Nicholson
or whoever was back there yeah this is
another piece for a really good
coordinator who I would put him ahead of
Mike Pettine that might be able to use
it my question for you is yeah where is
haha Clinton dicks because just like
Dante Fowler yeah I don't look at
Holland dicks is a former first-round
pick no I look at him as a above-average
safety yeah
that's really what he is I think I have
more hope for Fowler being something
that I do haha couldn't Dix how couldn't
Dix is underwhelming to me not that he's
about he's not a bad player and I'm not
trying to spread hate anybody than that
in that way but he doesn't pop off the
screen to me and doesn't do anything
extraordinary
yeah he's he hasn't lived up to where he
was drafted in the first round he is an
improvement for the Redskins though
don't get that mad yeah yeah and they
needed it so that's a good thing too and
you know what I'm excited more about
know that trade is what er Greenbay
gonna do so Josh Jones Josh Jackson Josh
Jones I would think his job do you think
Josh at this could be efficient move up
Josh Jackson is safe that's where he
should be he can't play in games like
last week like mud his ball skills are
phenomenal and he will tackle right so
he isn't that's where he is made for me
so the haha Clinton dick straight to
your mind is paving the way for Josh
Jackson the transition to safety or Josh
Jones who we and two years ago like
right he's got he's freakish athlete and
I think the other safety that they pair
him well they get the germane they throw
number 35 I'm blanking it's gonna look
it up yeah III can't think of every name
in the in the world right but it's
interesting for a Packers team that
still looked your main wife Jermaine
White had exactly right it's interesting
for a Packers team that thinks they
could be a playoff contender
yeah great away a guy it's interesting
yeah it is interesting and I think it's
just you know again with plays into
these decisions as the team just go he's
gonna be a free agent let's get
something for him now we're not gonna
pay him so let's do it look for my
number one in my number to Ikes a lot of
sense yeah because there was a guy
beneath them that they were going I want
to give that person more time
yes for this one I just wasn't sure and
you saying Josh Jackson could be the
safety there is very interesting yeah my
number two
Demaryius Thomas to the Houston Texans
Houston gave up a fourth round pick my
first question when I was looking at
this was throw Bryce the other safety
and gotcha was okay Hopkins to Marius
and I'm gonna say Kiki Katie yeah is the
other guy there I know a lot of people
are talking about Sammy coats but Kiki
was the one getting all of the reps yeah
and I looked up there 40 times too
Marius was a 4:38 he's not a 4:3 8:9
he's probably a four four six right Kiki
Katie was a four four three good speed
but they're replacing will fuller who
was the four three two and I went and
looked and it's been very well
documented about how deshaun Watson has
done with and without will fuller in the
line huh with Wolf fuller in the lineup
compared to without a hundred and
seventeen more yards per game two point
seven more yards per pass attempt and
one point five more touchdowns per game
two point five to one without will
fuller he's and in the fantasy world
it's like super drastic when I watch the
Texans game there's always the one will
fuller pass that either takes the soul
out of the defense or completely changes
the way that defense has to play them
the rest of the game because of fear we
saw it against Miami that was the kill
shot was willful or deep and the fact
that he tore his ACL on like a late game
20 is such a killer or the DeAndre
Hopkins when he's wide open and he ran
in the end zone and it was all because
of will fuller ran opposed to so you
guys went with it but the will fuller
touchdown allowed the Hopkins play a
little bit later to open up as they
wasn't there's that guy again right
Demaryius Thomas can he be that guy he
can not to the degree willful I mean
you're spot-on about will for its it's a
it's such a he has an elite trait he
does it's disappointing
it really is it's like a DeSean Jackson
so it just stinks that way Thomas the
Mariners can still do that he can still
run by people he is and he's got more of
a physical presence with some of the
other routes that he'll run than a will
fuller sure you know I don't want will
forward running in cuts and things over
the middle or doing that he's not gonna
break tackle no I'm worried he's gonna
get jammed and then the other guys gonna
pick him on yeah right right so those
yes they needed to do this the Houston
Texans you know also Demaryius has been
in this system a little already that's
the good thing because josh mcdaniels
drafted him so he has some familiarity
it's not gonna take too long and yes
they I like this move by them it had to
be done so it was a good job by Houston
yes and you
he's not gonna be will fuller though the
Broncos totally get it from their
perspective
they've been talking about this for a
while and Courtland Sutton needs to be
on the field more definitely because I
would argue that court in Sunderland
there's already more impressive than
Demaryius Thomas right now yeah I don't
even that's not even a question when I
watch Denver film every week I go I
always come away going damn this
Courtland sudden I mean he can run by
you he can jump over you he's he pops on
film how much of a playoff push does his
help with Demaryius Thomas well I think
there's like you're saying it's
necessary there they're a playoff
caliber football team but their offense
never is a blow you away
oh I never come away going whoa those
are some that was an amazing attack you
know they do it with you know good
running game taking a few shots
deshaun Watson please make a few plays
and then our defense is gonna mess a
whole lot of crap up on the other side
of the football that's the style play
they want to play and that's what stinks
because felt fuller fit exactly what
they want to do yes and Demaryius can do
that to a degree he can he's just not
gonna be quite as scary or dangerous to
opposing defense yeah my thing with
Demaryius is he's definitely had banged
up knees many people call them
degenerative yeah he drops the ball a
lot yes and I've heard of people saying
that like tired legs can lead to drop
balls later in your career but I will
also say he has not played with a
quarterback like this in about five
years you're right said I mean ate all
of the nonsense they've had right and
I'm a case keenum is in is a good
quarterback yeah but the simians the end
of Peyton Manning sure he probably
hasn't seen a ball toss while like he's
gonna see he's gonna go to Houston
practice today and he's gonna be like
holy crap he bet I'm curious if the
better ball leads to more drops or less
drops always less traps so I'm thinking
always because the tighter spiral the
Shawn just throw such a catchable it's
you know I know I wrote in my notes it's
just it's pure every time every time I
just go it's beautiful like a feather it
really is exactly right and the number
one most impactful trait of the deadline
fly fly it is not a homer pick it is
just Golden Tate to the Eagles they gave
back a third-round pick I'm gonna break
down some
mystics didn't know it last year the
Eagles were second in the NFL and third
down percentage remember I said this
before the year one of the reasons I had
the Eagles falling back was they were
absurd on the third down it was historic
and it wasn't gonna continue this year
they're 13th
yeah if you took away last Sunday for
the Eagles they go from 40 one person
excuse me forty four percent this year
to thirty nine percent they had a really
good day on third down before that
that's how bad it was also red zone
touchdowns hmm last year the Eagles were
second in the / in the possessions that
went to the red zone end in a touchdown
this year their 17th yeah Golden Tate is
like has three red zone touchdowns it's
one of his things yeah also Tate has the
moat he had the most touchdowns and
targets for Detroit in the red zone
third downs that led to first downs
hurts six Alshon eight Golden Tate ten
like great stats left that's what you're
looking for going third and seven or
more that led to first down Jordan
Matthews has three they're all that one
game Golden Tate has three so gold date
has more long third downs than anyone on
the Eagles yack Golden Tate is the 12th
most Yaak in the NFL he's the second
highest receiver all the other ones on
that list are running backs and tight
ends it just makes sense cuz they're
smaller pass right the only guy ahead of
him Albert Wilson who I would say
probably 80% of his yak was in that one
game against Chicago yeah you got a feel
like that right no one went has gotten
less yak from his receivers than Sam
Donald yeah and Sam Donald half of his
receiving core is on IR right now so
he's 21st in the NFL if you really think
about the Eagles offense Al Shean is a
catch and get tackled Ernst is a catch
and get tackled
Nelson Aguilar is the only guy that's
gonna break attack yards but I believe
that Elson Aguilar is a catch and
theatrically get tackled right like he
spins out and then does a thing and then
gets tackled one yard later right this
is the only guy that they have that's
gonna make a man miss and go yeah
which everyone's going on they think
they needed a deep guy or a guy that
could take something and go deep and I
think that's what's really opening it up
there and what howie Roseman has done
and said is what gets me a lot of
confidence what he's done the last three
trades a fifth round pick for Michael
Bennett a fourth round pick for Jay
Ajayi a third round pick for Golden Tate
I'm even go back a fifth round pick for
Darren Sproles and this is the quote he
said everyone's talking about it's so
funny to me the quotes that people look
at and think are great how you learned
what I said to you yesterday or did when
you were texting your friends or
whatever well no I'm not sure what you
said but you texted your friends about
what I say well my thing was just about
the notion of trading oh sorry
everyone's looking at the quote where he
says you got to keep your foot on the
gas whatever his quote were not trying
to win trades we're trying to get really
good players mm-hmm that's a notion that
I feel like everyone deals with even
with their fantasy team they're always
going I want to win the trade it's not
about that you're gonna have to give up
something we are in the Super Bowl
window you need to get the players to
win you the Super Bowl a third-round
pick at the end of the first round next
year is not guaranteed most of those
guys turn into special teams players
it's about getting good players and I
would say that of the the trades here
less need with the Rams making a move
how we Rosamond Golden Tate and Bryan
game down there in Houston doing what
they need to do in a rookie quarterback
window Gulf whence Watson trade those
middle round picks get guys that can
help you now and maximize the window I
think it was a genius trade I had no
issue with it absolutely not I mean
rosemon Howie Roseman said he's a
trendsetter he's done the next level
like with some of this stuff he's he's
blowing football way same thing with the
you know lesson each new rams like I
can't believe they traded for Sue I
can't believe they traded for the
littlest crap like you've always said
they stop all this crap that oh it's a
third-round pick like who gives a crap
there's so many third round bust first
round bust you don't know what it's
going to be so just like you made
all the great points and those were
great stats they really were because
they're third down red zone and yeah
they're only gonna help what I'm about
to say really I mean we've been saying
for three weeks it's it's too much work
for the Philadelphia offense its Carson
Wentz having to make amazing throws hang
in the pocket it's why you won the game
the other day it's the only reason you
won the game because he's amazing it's
just you're not gonna beat the best
teams of football that way last year you
know third down percentage to touch down
things you talked about well they were
good at that for one reason that was
really one reason I'll tell you why and
the big RPO swept in six and 20 that's
where I'm gonna tell you six and twenty
last year you were the sixth best
running offense in football this year
the 20th yeah you're not going to be
able to dominate in the run game not
what kind of injuries and the mismatch
of offensive lineman you better deal
with there just hasn't been that
continuity Gloria Clemente hasn't been
that guy right I got her rolls has
missed the whole year so they I think
Rosemond and and Peterson realize like
no we're gonna have to win it with old
number eleven Zoram this year yeah it's
gonna have to be and the past the short
passes to Tate can be the the part of
the running yeah exactly right and he's
explosive as hell he is our kind of guy
where we always go he is a wide receiver
in a running back body yes arm tackles
don't take Golden Tate down his
acceleration off the line of scrimmage
he's gonna be able to do Tyree killed
type of things in speed sweeps if you
guys want to start stealing some plays
from Kansas City Chiefs but he's also
gonna be able to catch slants and break
an arm tackle and get 20 yards and they
don't have that guy they don't have that
guy he is I know I know your friends
were saying this and then I continued my
friends one of my group chats were
talking about a vampire is Aguilar no
he's not he's a step up of the notch of
a human being an angular that's not a
disrespect to him but just as a notch of
a human not to be human being put that
in our dictionary dictionary right but
he is just as a physical specimen he's
power explosive acceleration and that's
what he's gonna bring to the table and I
would argues the best wide receiver
celebrator in the NFL yes he's a kind of
guy that you put on a team that's trying
to make a championship run right
surprise surprise
Michael
Bennet's got a ring a Chris Long has a
ring they had he's another guy with a
Super Bowl ring that knows what it
steaks and I know in that first game
against Dallas when he comes back after
this pot they bring him in on the buy so
he's got a whole week to adjust he
already hard either just so you know
he's been in Sderot bevels offense up
and it's the West Coast offense it'll
come very quick to him he just hung up
like a hundred and sixty and two
touchdowns against Dallas this season
right that was in that game should show
everybody itself but I mean Golden Tate
the first time he gets into the end zone
after breaking a tackle and does a
backflip in the end zone and then does a
celebration the team is juiced right
juiced yeah I agreed I also liked the
fact that you know again he's better
than Aguilar but they can both do the
same thing so then you don't get a beat
on what people do it's like the Robert
Woods Brandon cooks thing like yeah
Brandon cooks is better than Robert
woods but not a whole lot and they all
can do this there's no weakness to their
games so it's like feeling and digs it's
the same kind of thing so you just go
man I don't know you know some teams
have this is DeSean Jackson he runs deep
this is Mike Evans and he runs deep in
cuts oh okay that's what they do
you're not gonna know or have a beat on
which guy's gonna do which and I think
that's part of the beauty of it too 100%
yeah I I think it's and they're in this
for the long haul they're gonna sign
they're gonna see Golden Tate for three
weeks and they're gonna go it's not
gonna cost a lot to keep Golden Tate for
another three years you don't think he's
gonna want I think he wants a lot of
money got five years 31 when he was in
his prime he's not gonna be able to
demand more now at 31 he's a year 9
right yeah I went back and watched our
interview with him at the Super Bowl
yeah and he's a cool dude he spent about
40 seconds talking about the patriot way
which is really funny if he went to the
Patriots talking about how they do
everything right they're so disciplined
all along and then he said I need
another ring I need another ring he goes
my left arm is bringing me down on my
right arm if you remember that right and
I he's just another injection of energy
how we rose when there's a ball bat and
Dante Fowler just to get back to the COS
I didn't finish that to is just that I
think they're they gave her a third and
a fifth because they see potential and
Dante Fowler and they're gonna know
within
first three weeks if they want this guy
long-term and they're gonna dangle a
contract offering hey we can get you
million for four years some guaranteed
money you sure you want to leave that
out and gamble and not getting hurt in
the playoffs and you know who knows what
free agency is gonna be lit exactly
right cuz if you don't blow it out in
the oiss you want to fill a with Donald
I'll be cool yeah teams that and anyone
that you're surprised didn't make any
tray of course the Patriots I mean
that's the number one I just know
there's any chance that Bob Quinn was
like I just don't want to give Golden
Tate to the Patriots
yeah I could I could see that I could I
got Elway was like I'm not given to Mary
I was I could see that I could I would
be that way I mean let's think you would
do that yeah unless they just blew me
out there like if it was apples to
apples I dick [ __ ] New England yeah here
you go Houston yeah yeah I would
I'm surprised like I taught you a
pretender you're sick of them your
competitor the hell of them do you also
believe that Amari Cooper going for a
first rounder ruin the trade market uh I
don't believe it ruined it I just also
want to say really quickly
Cooper's 24 Tate's 31 various is thirty
so I understand why he cost more exactly
but hi unsealing is better with Cooper
but there's also more questions with
Cooper than Golden Tate so that's all I
think I would fight back against that
notion there's a lot of unproven things
that I need to see with Amari Cooper
Golden Tate I know what I'm getting and
that's that's it
I texted Golden Tate last night and we
had a lot of curse words and I was just
like [ __ ] yeah you're on the champions
he was like haha he's like man I'm
excited I'm gonna get in there buh ah
all right and then come on the podcast
next Wednesday listen I Nelson I'm the
booking producer yeah I go that time
Chris has been the Booker for three
years so so both of you miss it that was
sarcastic yeah I'm still get it done
tell him to come here too as you hear
the game this weekend that it's gonna be
I mean there's a matchup at quarterback
this weekend that I think is so
tailor-made for our show
that we have talked about this for years
a lot of fun games it does but to me
nothing really encapsulates what we're
gonna witness for hold on tell me who
are only to say are you going sarcastic
Raiders Niners right I mean I was gonna
say Brock Osweiler Sam Darnell but now
it's pretty Rogers and we have to talk
about it we don't often look ahead at
the games but I think Brady and Rogers
is one of those things everyone's
talking about the goat I'm actually very
surprised that so much of the content
coming out this week is more Pro rogers
than Pro Brady I'm seeing a lot of
people going what if Rogers played with
Belichick and usually I feel like you're
right I have feel like there's I feel
like the pendulum has swung a little bit
like and I think we should take credit
for it really okay fine that that we at
least have opened people's eyes that
this is a very real discussion and get
over the rings thing mmm when Michael
Jordan says it's a discussion I guess
you're right [ __ ] Ahmad you're probably
to go to me think the NBC Michael Jordan
right I mean you're like adds to it
certainly we've been saying it and by we
I mean the two of you have been saying
it for a long time but when Michael
Jordan starts the week by saying it's a
debate about the time that legitimizes
it for people of oh okay maybe it is a
debate you right there's been a ton of
quotes that have come out recently that
we've always wanted Brady to say yeah
about Rogers the Ian O'Connor article of
course where he said I'm really a
product of what I've been around who I
was coached by what I played against in
the air I played in I appreciate Brady
self-awareness what's awesome vibrating
it's again it's really is yeah you know
what it's what I love about time that's
actually something well Rogers is
complimentary of people he is but Brady
Brady
has the hardware and all that to like
kind of he could shove it in everybody's
face and be like he can he can end that
discussion almost or find ways to
finagle I'm gonna do his corny I plead
the first something like that right but
he he's that's what I I appreciate that
about Tom Brady I really appreciate
everything about Tom Brady quote from
Aaron Rodgers is college coach Chuco it
will be limitless what Aaron would have
done with Belichick in that organization
he has all the intangibles Brady
and has better armed talent better
athlete I think Aaron would have won
four or five championships - you agree
with that
you think he won one seven I mean I
think he might have been in a hole more
Super Bowls I don't think they would
have lost maybe some of the AFC
championship games they lost a man just
that's what kind of talent I think Aaron
I think Aaron Rodgers is like
once-in-a-lifetime type talent that's
how special I think he is just how we
rattled off stats yesterday you know the
thing that I always come back to forget
I we think he's the most physically
gifted guy ever but the quickest of
40-thousand the quickest of 300 td's
you're really not gonna ever know a
marquee name that played receiver a
tight end for him and then he shape or
fashion and then the interception of the
touchdown ratio he's the greatest
gunslinger and the history of the sport
but yet he meant he takes care of the
ball better than the greatest game
managers in the history of the sport
just to hammer home that touchdown
interception ratio yeah
all-time the number three touchdown
interception ratio guy is Russell Wilson
yeah two point nine five five the number
two is Tom Brady 3.0 - so 7/100 better
than number three and really below that
you know you go down point five you go
down point six
Aaron Rodgers is four point one three
the margin between two and three is
7/100 the margin between Aaron Rodgers
and Tom Brady is one point one one like
it's so it's it's insane insane that's
that's all I've been trying to say to
people and Tom Brady is off first of all
let me just say it like this my favorite
athlete outside of football and maybe
like okay no Michael Jordan LeBron James
is Derek Jeter okay and Derek Jeter is
awesome like awesome the cautious guy
I've ever seen and that's where Brady is
awesome that's where I look at Brady
Brady's physical ability gets
undervalued he yeah okay he looks gawky
and like Bambi sometimes when he runs
for a first down or tries to catch the
quarterback pass in the Super Bowl but
his sliding in the pocket I would tell
you is you know as good as the all-time
greats you know it's it's up
there with anybody I mean Rogers is the
all-time great in the pocket but Brady
is up there with the Dan Marino's and
and the Rogers and all of that
discussion he's amazing a having feel
and sliding and staying in a throwing
position his arm talent Tom Brady it
does not get enough credit Tom Brady's
arm talent playing in New England
playing in Buffalo the other night
throwing piss missiles through the one
across the field to Edelman was a rocket
right that was a rocket I remember that
one I was like oh right like you know
again I've caught balls for Tom Brady
and practice Tom Brady can really throw
that mf'er he really can it's it's
impressive what he can do and that's
another thing I think it's undervalued
about Brady I really do I think it's one
of the all-time great arms you know it's
not Rogers arms cuz Rodgers is the
greatest arm ever and as you heard and
Tom Brady said on the radio station this
week he said it's the greatest arm he's
ever seen his ability to throw the
football is like anyone in the history
of the league yes also know why right so
you know again it's just it's a
fascinating it's gonna be a fascinating
game but you're gonna see one guy who's
41 and nobody's done it better or longer
than Tom Brady that is though that is
undeniable you never take that away from
him
that is for sure but you're gonna see
one guy that Brady is great and they're
gonna execute offense and he's gonna
make some big throws but then you're
gonna see Green Bay there's gonna really
just be damn 12 make magic and that's
what it's going to be and so with all
that little help Aaron Rodgers would
have to throw zero touchdowns and 29
straight interceptions for Brady to have
the same touchdown interception ratio
wow that's amazing it's almost as good
as your huge accident Bill Belichick's
that say that one too we you know that
was actually wrong completely incorrect
400 games off it was like it's like 877
like belcheck would have to lose 877 go
guess the point the funniest thing is
that a thousand 177 someone put it
online I went with oh my gosh Abington
friends way high school stories the my
favorite thing though about Belichick
talking about Aaron Rahal's I really
wish we could print out the transcript
from four years ago
oh no this is from what he said today
because social call was amazing I will
never forget that moment
so someone I guess asked about comparing
Aaron Aaron and Tom I'm only gonna read
you the first paragraph in where
Belichick talked up Tom
in order to probably make him feel
better and not just gloat about Rob
because this is what he did in the mass
matchup when they went to Green Bay he
was asked the same question and he kind
of was like he didn't take any he didn't
do disrespect but he kind of tried to
say like no this is like this is a
different animal we're playing here guys
quote I've never played against Tom
Brady so I'm glad he's our quarterback
he's a great quarterback he's won a lot
of games for us hopefully he'll went a
lot more we've Lana won a lot of games
because of him but I've never played
against Tom Brady so this is a different
context doesn't talk about his physical
ability does it just talks about winning
games so then he goes on to talk about
Aaron Rodgers it's as difficult as a
game you can play he's as good as
anybody I've ever faced we faced a lot
of good ones just saying this guy is a
great player he can do everything a
quarterback needs to do throws
touchdowns no interceptions and then he
also says this he's thrown however many
long passes to however many different
receivers it's not all one guy like he
knows what he's going up against he also
said Jair Alexander is phenomenal and he
wish he could have drafted him but he
wasn't there and they got a great player
and he was the top guy on our board but
he was their top guy on their board he
said he was at the top of their board
yeah yeah I know him and Hughes I you
know yeah he's Jair was off-the-charts
Isis do you guys think that Rodgers is
the type of guy who's extra juiced for
this one because of how much attention
is on it and the Brady Rodgers
discussion I mean they're both gonna be
extra juiced I think Rob Brady would
probably be more juice likely has to go
into the game going
I got to do it like headon already has
to half that juice because there are six
and ten team without him that's
brainless Brady could not have a Drew
Brees Sunday Night Football Minnesota
game like they can't win by 10 and he
only throws for 120 because that would
just perfectly illustrate the matchup
you're right
Brady Brady in his mind to what you're
saying probably feels like he's like I
gotta get 300 yeah and really like
Brady's has a losing record against what
I think like only this is one of the
he's only he hasn't beat
Rogers has him one oh I think Cam Newton
has them two to one hmm and I think
Russell Wilson has him two to one those
are the only three quarterbacks I think
so I think Tom thinks about those things
too to go leg yeah yeah of course I
would be I will say this though what's
funny about Rodgers is we always say
when you're listening to people
compliment listen to what they
compliment when you're talking about
Blake bortles they talk about the
leadership is running ability they never
mention the arts what they don't mention
yeah when people criticize Aaron Rodgers
they criticize his attitude his
relationship with his family it's always
me one Super Bowl but it's never it's
really more like it's a shame if they
don't win another one with him it's not
a right criticizes but all the criticism
it's not about his play yeah it's about
his personality his family relationships
you know which says a lot I think you're
very good at pointing you reverse that
it's interesting from that perspective
so I do think though I do not know of
Aaron Rodgers and Bill Belichick would
have been able to get along together why
I think I in the article was interesting
they were talking about who was his
coach Tom Brady at Michigan Lloyd Carr
and apparently he was a super
disciplinarian - right and Tom Brady I
think is an all-time is a Hall of Fame
coachable player as well yeah we always
talk about you know Aaron's the kind of
guy and I'm gonna get into personality
thing yeah where I don't I don't know
how you would have taken it I think you
have to look at it as like molding
people right it's like so you think if
it happened from the beginning yeah and
also I would say how much of Aaron
Rodgers mentality is because he played
under far for four years sure he had to
learn some afar it's the element of the
organization their organization for you
know 25 years now has been hey great
quarterback you're on a pedestal carry
us and that's what he's nuts all he's
your versus nurture right and Brady and
it's not disrespect but he comes in and
they just go quarterback shut up and
listen to what we tell you to do and
it's just a different type of thing and
you learn to go okay let's step in line
damn when I listen to coach
we win so I'm just gonna keep doing that
and I think that's that's where I would
just push back against that notion to a
degree yeah so what you're gonna eat
report put out the video last night on
Twitter of you guys talking about Brady
versus Rogers right and under it
they put a poll one drive to win the
game who you got Aaron Rogers Tom Brady
Oh sixty-three thousand people voted on
Twitter Wow
59% when Aaron Rodgers why do you one
percent Tom Brady Wow so I would still
take Tom Brady for onedrive you would my
as I said in the show Aaron Rodgers I
feel like I'm watching a moment Tom
Brady I feel like it's inevitable where
Tom with that I think you're taking the
team wolf course how can I evaluate I'm
just saying so if you put Tom Brady
behind some of the Aaron Rodgers
offensive lines at receivers that go dim
that their browsers has had more bad
driving Kowboy Aaron Rodgers has had
more Pro Bowlers on his offensive line
than Tom Brady yeah okay fine I've been
I've just say a system in general yeah
that's fine
that's that's fine that's you know Tom
Brady it's it's a it's a March yes it is
it's 11 plays a minute and 20 perfectly
executed knowing the time getting the
ball out time outs before the ref even
looks up right Aaron Rodgers is its
fourth and 17 right and I'm gonna roll
out do a pirouette stiff arm a defensive
lineman throw it 60 yards on a line
which which last Drive do I want to
watch more Aaron Rodgers yeah which
drive would I feel more confident in Tom
Brady I know I still think you're taking
the team there I think you're just there
in fourth and 17 because they ran three
plays before that that Tom Brady goes we
don't run those plays though here
perfect Tom Brady would know how to get
out of his place it's that's the thing
about Tom Brady it's it's awesome it's
amazing and he's that's what I was
saying with the Derek Jeter thing the
clutch factor is off the charts the
funniest thing about Michael Jordan
doing that is literally 10 minutes
before in my other group chat I were
doing MBA comparisons for NFL players
which I'd love to bring to this podcast
one time and I said really Brady is
Jordan and LeBron is Aaron Rodgers
LeBron had to do it by himself he does
not have all the Rings Tom Brady has all
the hardware just like Michael Jordan
but he also had Phil
Jackson and a great supporting staff
that you can kind of give some of the to
that was the combination right and when
you make it that way I understand that
yeah yeah and I said Kobe is Payton
Kobe's pay yeah [ __ ] allegations off
the field
you know he's played for a few different
coaches DIF two different eras the firt
like he was not as important the first
time yeah stuff like that I don't know I
mean it those are fun conversations that
they Rock Rogers Elway Brady is your top
three oh sorry Kobe has been
Roethlisberger I apologize Elway Brady
yeah yeah and it's it's very close but
Elway to me is in that that Rogers
category physical ability yeah where it
just was like gosh man that 86 Giants
they dial up all the right defenses in
the first half of that Super Bowl game
it didn't matter cuz John just said well
I'll just run over here I can outrun
Jill or instead Lord the edge and then
I'm gonna spot up and throw a 60 yard
missile down the field and screw your
cover to or whatever else Bill Belichick
you can't stop me and that's that's you
know I put a lot into that you know I do
I said that Elway is either wilt or Shaq
both are just like a physical dominance
like it's it's always in there like Shaq
you could always argues the best NBA
player that ever lived you go one-on-one
he would dominate you like he was the
most dominant right that was Elway yeah
I mean he was amazing
well that's see this is like a good
offside is a good offseason topic no way
is like freakishly strong that's the
onlythe always thing i would always come
back to like always a big thick guy he's
he's uh you know a 350 pound power
cleaner like Rogers are breathing ain't
doing that no no there's like the
weights gonna pick them up before they
weight room which on Elway well I just
know the stories but through the
Shannons through being through bill
Romanowski back in the day cuz he used
to come train down at Texas of the track
coach and do all that and he would tell
all these stories about what a freak
John Elway was and yeah that's that's
crazy stuff one quarterback that we saw
get disrespected after his performance
and a kind of took us off guard and I
want to be a little delicate about this
is Kirk Cousins yeah our friend our
colleague Mike Freeman works up
lead to report I like his work he came
out and he wrote an article saying that
the Vikings made an eighty four million
dollar mistake yeah and I saw the
headline and said man those headline
makers they took his work out of context
and then I read the article and it was
like talking about how Kirk Cousins is
like an average quarterback and Sunday
was a perfect example of how he's bad
the interception of Stefon he was trying
to find Stefon Diggs is taken back to
the house I'm gonna be honest and and
and I mean this with all due respect I
couldn't agree more with the entire
piece disagree more disagree more with
the entire piece Kirk Cousins is playing
phenomenal right now Kirk Cousins in my
mind is a top 10 quarterback in this
league I agree and and I I get upset
because I don't want people to even
think that could be true now as I feel
like it's completely false it is false
and we need to correct that narrative
you know I think the big thing is first
of all I know that play do this I
because it's just it's the narrative
that was started started at the
beginning in Washington start a fan that
always like fan the flame there with
that discussion because I always take it
back to the fact that he kind of ended
the dream child's chances the guy they
looked at a right rg3 and we got our guy
and he was the thorn in the side that
kind of ruined this dream of what could
have been which is not true rg3 ruined
that everybody but the the thing i think
i would push back with that and that
notion first of all is i know the play
he threw the interception on yes okay
the interception 72x shallow cross it's
a staple of West Coast offense I could
tell you the reads what you do
everything about it Stefon Diggs does
that fall in the interception he is
admitted it already he's not supposed to
stop running it's man-to-man it's a
shallow cross you don't stop and sit up
in a zone on a shallow cross just for
everyone out there to teach you so yes
there was Mike's take on that was you
still shouldn't have thrown it and it's
like that's not it that's not real
that's just not fair that's it's just
not fair to say oh you're still stood in
the throat well if he kept running it
would have been incompletion I don't
know what to say you know there's the
fourth and one that they go for you know
Mike Zimmer messes up that play call in
the third quarter Danny threw the ball
down the middle of the laQuan Treadwell
and he dropped it right I mean damn so
now he's got to catch the ball too but
so that's the thing
don't like about it and everyone I think
is just going well Minnesota last year
was 13 and 3 and they've already lost
three games this year so they're not as
good at its cuz of Kirk Cousins they
just look at the biggest name on the
roster and they go that's why that's the
reason how about the offensive line has
been in shambles how about their run
game as it is good how about John D
Philipose not as good offensive
coordinators Pat Shermer how about like
their winning games because of Kirk
Cousins or tying Green Bay with a 22
point fourth quarter because he makes
unbelievable throws or the win in
Philadelphia cuz of unbelievable throws
or the win in New York with unbelievable
throws and yet there he is marching them
and they're surgical as hell and it's 13
to 10 and Adam Thielen fumbles and we're
gonna go back and go Kirk Cousins lost
the game I just that to me blows my mind
yeah I am totally with you he is one of
the 10 best quarterbacks in football and
yeah that was frustrating cuz not only
him but there was a few people I heard
that kind of talked with this week yeah
I I know there's some guys that I feel
like we over inflate automatically
whenever they do something and there's
certain guys that we always minimize
what they do yeah cam is one of those
guys Kirk Cousins is one of those guys I
think Russell Wilson is one of those
guys guys that do great things and we
only talk about their negatives and for
some reason give credit to the team the
franchise when they do stuff right
doesn't make sense one person that's
been getting very attacked lately has
been Jalen Ramsey a lot of people saying
you used to talk and now you don't talk
how they're attacking about it huh yeah
that's what he always happens well I
don't know how it happened I do know
it's because of Old Spice we got Jalen
Ramsey on the podcast little 10 15
minute interview yeah and apparently
Jalen Ramsey knows who we are he likes
us and Sims even talked to him about
Blake bortles so enjoy the legend has
arrived you guys doing all right you
doing all right man yeah all right we're
gonna have fun all right yeah I'm tired
of seeing all these people wait you said
you all you you always do you say like
you know us you've you've seen this
before
haha I don't believe you me likey you
more we've already started go ahead give
them the intro alright I gotta get the
intro we are joined by the most
beautiful quarterback in the NFL when I
say beautiful
I mean he'll shut you down I'll talk in
your face and then they'll spin the ball
the end zone and say get out of my face
I'm Jalen Ramsey and we have Jalen
Ramsey because of who Old Spice foamer a
foaming body wash that lathers in a
flash upgrade your shower experience
with Old Spice Homer from your local
Walmart Sims I used the phone oh I like
it you know I mean any really is
handsome I mean he fits my you know
super star corners can only be handsome
Jalen Sims has a theory they that most
great players the NFL are attractive do
you agree we've talked you up for so
long and it's been fun to watch the
national media and all the fans go man I
love this guy even from the draft coming
out of Florida State Simms was obsessed
with you yeah obsessed with you in fact
this is the first place I want to go
okay Jalen you are the best corner in
football I don't question that one bit
who is number two and you can cannot
answer AJ booyah that is not an
acceptable answer
no it's not we do think he's number two
number two but we want to know other
than AJ yeah who is the hell of this
Jalen Ramsey's one AJ buiiets - who's
number three I would have to say yes I
have to say the legend Pepe look at the
video he's got the speed he's got
complete punt return key did you study
him at all of course yeah that was when
my idols are growing up especially like
in high school I Ward under 7 in high
school damn that's awesome and now
you're in the league with them that's
really cool yeah where do you want to go
next
well I mean the next thing I always like
to go with Jalen Ramsey is like toughest
receiver he's had to defend so far in
your NFL career like who was the one guy
who said damn after the game was over
like that guy was a handful
putting you on the spot today yeah yeah
this is tough want me to read you some
names just to throw them out there just
to keep it fresh here I want him to say
Tyree kill ya you can you can't okay
well of course there is Tyree kill which
I apparently think he's better than you
do after your comments a few weeks ago
okay but DeAndre Hopkins Julio Jones
Mike Evans
you know yet Davante Adams Antonio Brown
Antonio Brown of course yes
Odell Odell beast yes although it's hard
to pick one honestly I would have to say
d-hop or Antonio just because I've I
mean I played II hop what what is it
it's been ty times now yeah I played
Antonio twice even in my one match up
against out there this year it was a
tough matchup really good night sir so
yeah I guess I would say those three
guys talk about Hopkins you saw Hopkins
got a new running mate today
Demaryius Thomas and did I see that yeah
sorry first thought is we got another
weapon
I was like man he's got another weapon I
make it hard on it's over here yeah
that's what they're doing I already have
a great quarterback in my opinion to
sign now here you know weapons on
weapons d ha you know will fuller went
down for him hope you recover well but
then they just win got him
so I mean that's great what what is it
you know you talked about Watson and I
know you got to play my home's early in
the year like what you know what what a
they're the two best young quarterbacks
in the sport right now and we get throw
carson wentz probably in that
conversation you know what was kind of
unique about all three preparing for
them and playing against them on the
field all of them are you know they can
make big plays honestly where there's
throwing or running
they're just playmakers and in every
sense of what the word means that's who
they are they're playmakers they're good
leaders for their team and they have all
they were all tough opponents who would
you take of the three right now mahomes
watson or whence I've actually never
thought of this question actually never
because they're all awesome yeah I would
go mahomes right now I think I would I
think I would too and you're not wrong
we're not trying to make it no the
answer is no never wrong these are all
these are all awesome I'm going home so
um you know left cause a huge Eagles fan
to Ramsay sorry just so you know so I
mean he is last week was the first time
he ever routed against here just so
yours I'm ever I don't know I would
probably go with the sign mmm this
because I mean in my career playing
against him has dated back to college
anyway yeah so I I really like his game
man and it seems like it's starting to
click I picked no offense
I picked a Houston Texans to go to the
Super Ball I didn't pick the Jaguars but
I feel really good about it right now
yeah we'll beat your ass later left god
yeah
sorry next time Jalen's here in New York
so Jalen I I am someone that studies the
game but I also study the way that
people cover the game and I've been
fascinated with watching how your
relationship with the media is like
evolving and changing all the time
you go from a guy that it's like little
clips from the locker room and then all
of a sudden like there's these big GQ
expose s and everyone's hanging on your
last word and then like during this
losing streak
everyone's like ganging up on you all of
a sudden and like feeling like now they
can take their chance to come at you and
they're all asking you one question
right now and that question is how do
you fix it and you're going why am I the
only player in the NFL that has to come
up with on the top of my head a
two-minute answer on how to fix the team
when it's a team sport with coaches I
have I have an answer that you can give
and okay so Sims and I have been talking
about this for a long time about
defensive schemes of the NFL and there's
one scheme that a lot of teams are
running right now the Seattle scheme
that you guys are running that Gus
Bradley ran and how many other teams run
at Sims gosh there's
probably about 11 in about 8 8 or 9
right now that are running that same
defensive scheme and Sims you've always
said Jacksonville has the dogs right to
do more man a man and mix it up a little
bit right and that's my solution that's
actually sim as a solution I just stole
that's okay that's you're allowed to I'm
curious do you feel the same way that
like man maybe we need to change it up
more maybe people are used to this
scheme so much I mean am i off base
there have you ever thought about that
we just wanna hear you talk about it
I've never really thought that to be
honest I I think when it comes down to
it to be honest it's just it's executing
it I think it's a good scheme I think we
have a good defensive scheme but we have
to go out there and execute it when ten
are doing it right and then maybe one is
doing it wrong that can mess up the
whole place so we all really have to be
on the same Accord that's wine out there
playing is wine and and it'll work it'll
work out I'm very optimistic about what
we have left in season you have eight
games left so I know weekend we can turn
this thing around
Oh Jim what we want to be dealing down
you're going to like if you were a stock
right now I'm buying Jacksonville stock
because everyone everyone's jumping on
you guys right now you guys are gonna
come out after this buy a team on a
mission [ __ ] Andrew Luck yeah that like
I really feel bad for all the
quarterbacks that are gonna play you
guys with all this momentum speaking of
quarterbacks Jalen I don't know if you
know the guy I'm sitting next to all of
the bortles nonsense
he gets kind of the credit for because
he said bortles was the 70th best
quarterback in the NFL and I was curious
if there was member
yeah is there anything you'd like to say
to Chris okay that's a good answer I was
born in Moore I was getting ready for
worse I thought are you gonna call me
like some dumb MF or something like that
well yeah okay you know I know I how do
you handle everyone talking [ __ ] about a
player that you have to defend because
he's on your team not saying that he's
not warranted but like it puts you guys
in a weird spot yeah I mean media media
and answering media questions isn't
always the easiest thing to do but you
have to you have to
you have to do it as professionally as
you can or you can you know kind of not
talk but then I mean really it's it's
whatever it take you want to take people
have their opinion if you talk if you
don't talk if you give it inside if you
don't give an insight by the end of the
day I just want all my teammates know I
support them okay done well done I don't
really care about what anything yes no
you can't I mean that's how you got for
that good answer my other thing for you
jaylen is are you guys sitting there
looking at Leonard going man when we
come out of this pie we're excited to
have you back on the field yeah we are a
lot for sure we know uh first and
foremost he had to get healthy and we
didn't want to you know rush him back
possibly again and have him riri injure
himself or anything like that because we
know when he is in there and he's that
fool go
he's danger and we would love that it I
would love to see and we'll let you go
cuz we know you got to go here but I
want to ask one more thing because I
mean first of all you're one of my
favorite teams to watch and that's kind
of why I hated um Blake bortles for a
little bit because I see the greatness
on your roster you have more superfreaks
and guys that I got man crushes on on
your football team than any other team
in football but I want to know from your
point of view who is the freakiest guy
on your football team as an athlete or
you just look at and go wow um I mean
you got John Coffey and coleus Campbell
you got Myles Jack you got all these
freaks men that I just I'm amazed by I
know that's why we're sips at left go
that's why we're a big deal of bleacher
before we put you on the spot I don't
know but I'll tell you how if we were in
a larger room having this conversation
the answer will be me yeah well yes I
figured that what a big yes I'm gonna
have to go with that okay like a true
corner
all right saw one last question before I
sign out here how do you take your steak
my
stay like eating yeah medium-well yeah
alright so Sims and I are team like well
done medium well right and we think that
people that do medium rare rare kind of
crazy as nasty yes
that's nasty to me now I'm fully
confirmed on the medium-well bandwagon
Jalen John alright so again with uh I
you're always with us Jalen this is
again compliments of new Old Spice
foamer head to Walmart check it out a
foaming body wash that lathers in a
flash kick ass rest up enjoy the week I
love seeing that video this offseason
about you working out your pops you're
you're great dude man and I we wish you
all the best
yeah we're rooting for you I appreciate
it I genuinely mean what I said to him I
do think the Jaguars are gonna be a
second-half team this year I think
they're gonna come back strong I think
going to London and getting a buy is
exactly what the team needed yeah I
don't like when teams are riding high
and hit the buy but when they or they
need a bounce back hit the buy it could
change it alright and Leonard fournette
is gonna be back healthy I mean yeah I
would not want to be Andrew Luck and the
Annapolis cults after this bye cuz oh
hey he is gonna play a pissed off bunch
yeah and every focused bunch that'll be
very intrusive airy capable of going on
a run here just look at their next four
games it's at Colts its Pittsburgh ok
that'll be tough but we know that they
can play with Pittsburgh it's at Buffalo
and then it's back to the Colts hmm so
if they could win all four of these
games and then all of a sudden you go
damn there's seven and five you know
watch out for Jacksonville then it's the
Tennessee Titans the week after that you
know so they're still very much in the
thick of this I'm talking up on them we
talked to jaylen an hour and a half
before the Dante Fowler trade yeah
because he's Chris said right after he
was gonna ask if dr. Fowler was gonna
get moved I really I had a feeling of
that he was definitely one of those guys
that was on my radar to go Dante Fowler
guys they were coming up on a new
country right the team might not right
and like we said they drafted the first
round earth you asked Jalen Ramsey who
is the biggest freak on the team yeah he
said if I was in the locker I picked me
who would you have picked
I would pick Myles
ooh it to me between Ramsay Jack and
fournette those not class Campbell well
I like not Yannick and got quite I mean
coleus is like definitely a freak but
more in the giant size freak kind of way
where these guys are like you know
because yeah it could put the ball
between their legs and do a windmill
dunk and do stuff like that that's where
I just go like that's crazy and then
they can go oh you want us to race them
the hundred meter and the Olympics this
week okay we'll just line up we haven't
trained for it and they'd be like in the
top five and you beg what the hell like
that's what kind of guys they are
so it is week eight going into week nine
and I thought it's a good chance for us
to look back at our awards and what we
thought was gonna happen and since it's
halfway through the year see how we're
doing like you kept in Offensive Rookie
of the Year Sims you said say Quan
Barclay do you feel like he's still got
a good chance I do
who who are the other rookies that are
like well I said a Denver rookie running
back boy I nailed it
Phillip Lindsey that's a good job I
didn't I said Royce Freeman I know but
but to your point and I think me and
Josh were watching games this Sunday and
we were thinking about you because when
Phillip Lindsey went off I said you know
this was actually Thursday night I was
like Sims is really good at identifying
running backs in two stages
he usually identifies one running back
during the draft process that he likes
and then he identifies another running
back after watching preseason and he
goes I don't know why this guy wasn't
looked at and Phillip Lindsey was that
guy this year and Phillip Lindsey right
now is six in the NFL in rushing behind
Gurley Zeke Connor hunt and ap the backs
ahead of Lindsey each have 127 carries
or more and lindsay has 93 who he's
averaging five point seven yards per
carry nobody in front of him is
averaging over four point seven every
time Lindsey touches the ball it's wow
like even that Denver Kansas City game
yeah I want to know another reason why
Denver lost because Lindsey had two runs
for twenty or more that were both called
back four holes right and they don't
even think there
yeah but Phillip Lindsey every time he
touches the ball out man it's got a
little LeSean McCoy in him but it's a
but he's faster than maybe not quite as
quick but a little more fast it's the
shiftiness LaShawn than just a yeah it's
special it's a very technical term man
Colorado you know I just I look at him
and then no wonder they snuck up on
people I but you know interested
bringing it just brought another like
the Seattle D guy Tedric Thompson number
he's another Colorado guy man number 33
Paul Richardson I mean yeah but he I
mean this time Tom's he is he is like I
I can see why they said hey we're not
that worried if you want to leave Earl
or Cam this guy's special he will knock
your head off
who we missing for Rookie of the Year
yeah office before we do that Aaron
Rodgers was just asked about the goat
conversation and he said quote he's got
five championships I think that ends the
discussion see didn't have to talk about
any of his physical traits being better
than him he said rings rings it's great
yeah okay I do think there's a true
mutual respect there like no doubt about
it yeah I would hope so other rookies on
offense that were drafted in the first
round
Sam darn old Quentin Nelson like John
Shanks McGlinchey rose in Eugene Moore's
too far behind yeah a lot of sinners
frag now business the obvious one was
the obvious Calvin Ridley when you're
that common really has a chance but
probably not a shot penny Sony Michele
the thing that's gonna get sake one is
if he goes a thousand and a thousand but
she has a chance to do what you called
did I call I know you said he you said
that you thought he could get a 2000
all-purpose yards right that's a
thousand and a thousand yeah
Defensive Rookie of the Year you picked
row Kwan Smith I picked Minka
Fitzpatrick hmm either of them standing
out I don't think they're gonna win it
no I mean I think that
Derwin James would be the first one very
good one right I don't even think Roe
Kwon is performed as well as Jermaine
Edwards Edmonds Edmonds every moments on
Monday night Edmonds has a presence in
the middle of the field that is yeah and
you know what I would say Darius Leonard
is probably the favor
oh that's that's it like that sort of 17
tackles a game
right I need to pull up the draft just
to look at names real quick but oh you
got I don't think it's really worth it
but okay well chub is gonna be in it cuz
BB because he's like seven sacks right
now right he's in the these up there in
that conversation so yeah I mean nhi
here Alexander maybe yes Doron pains
been phenomenal but they're not gonna
give that to that guy so I would think
Derwin James Darius Leonard
Darius Leonard hey Denzel Ward deserves
some sugar for sure you know Jai air I
feel like has just come on because he
dealt with an ankle injury I mean a
groin injury excuse me but yeah I think
those would be the leader in the house
let me just go to round two just to make
sure we're not missing anybody here sure
but it Darius Leonard man he is freaking
awesome I mean he really is I know I
hope he can last for a long time I hope
begin to that's I would worry about that
he is gonna he's in a lot of car crashes
and Avante Maddox the new starting
safety for the Eagles is pretty
fantastic fumble for sir uh yeah I think
we're right there Defensive Player of
the Year
you said miles Garrett I said Yannick
and Gok way it's Aaron Donald yes like I
don't even think it's close no it's
Aaron Donald
and if Khalil Mac didn't get hurt a few
weeks ago I think it would be just
between those two yeah they they have in
my mind separated themselves you believe
that Aaron Donald and Khalil Mac are the
two best defenders in the NFL and
there's a gap to third I do I think
there's a gap to third I think they have
separated themselves and we haven't seen
the real coil Mack the last few weeks
but we certainly have seen the real
Aaron Donald that was unbelievable what
he did in that game the other day and
yeah he's he's unblockable and so was
Khalil Mac he's unbelievable too but yet
they they are earning what their
contracts are and justifying it for sure
how our f the play up guys doing you
picked Stephan to it and I picked
Fletcher Cox yeah - it has not had the
year I would have expected it's full
good but not great Fletcher is still he
is still a F the play up King he is up
in that category yes it's just so funny
that we always talk about the best
players the NFL and people debate
quarterbacks and all that and somebody
like Fletcher Cox just never gets
mentioned and he's not always destroying
the other no I mean I would say Aaron
Donald's probably the best
play up guy this year too uh I was a
hundred percent say that left go I I
think you know other guys that if we
just wanted to throw into that
conversation for F the plays up just
that off the top of my head you know hey
Akeem Hicks in Chicago man he pops a lot
with F and some plays up
who else I'm missing another one you
know JJ Watt he is either way you either
way you want to go Defensive Player of
the Year at the play up he does a lot of
it to Chris Jones is that a good Harris
Jones does have a good year no doubt
about that
clowny yep I feel like I'm missing
somebody else but I think those are the
main ones that I just look on a weekly
basis and go man that is a lot of
disruption there oh you know our guy
Mike Daniels with the Green Bay Packers
has his momentum are Lawrence yeah those
those type of guys are all up there but
you know your original thought with with
our big man Aaron Donald is is correct
and then MVP we both picked Aaron
Rodgers and I don't think he's winning
MVP it's gonna have to be some type of
run I think if he didn't hurt his mohawk
or Gurley right now right now and
they're a notch above everybody else
yeah yeah they're playing a video game
and everybody else is playing real life
football yeah alright so you're ready to
dive into your film notebook Sims let's
do it always really quick just some
other notes Doron pain well miles
Garrett doesn't he's second in football
in sacks
Geron pain has as many sacks with
Washington as he did in three years with
Alabama which goes to what you said
about what they asked you to do at
Alabama evaluate what's being asked to
do of the player when you evaluate
coming out of the draft you can't just
go well he never gets to the quarterback
well if they're telling him not to get
to the quarterback then yeah he's not
gonna get there and that's not what his
job was you have to take that into
account when you evaluate players yeah
I'm just gonna rip through these really
quick before we go for the film this
have impacts you since 1976 the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers have drafted 25
quarterbacks and how many is sorry how
many of them have signed a second
contract with the team technically I did
Oh answers none no I did I did I signed
a three-year deal they realized that I
had talent and they gave me a three-year
deal and then what happened then why
isn't it I don't know because I got it's
a crud
I don't know why cuz I wasn't a real
free agent maybe so I did a three-year
deal and then became a restricted free
agent and got high tendered as a first
and a third sign that deal lost my
spleen signed another deal huh so who
did that stab they need to call them
morning you want to know who did it they
need to sell scout themselves you can
talk to him about it on the radio
tomorrow cuz he wrote an article about
it Floria yeah who else do you talk to
on the radio okay I will I will bring it
up
um wouldn t one another the perfect
example right now when someone brings up
statistics to you he brought he I he
asked about you today - do you want to
know the perfect example if you're
arguing so about statistics eli has more
passing yards than Brady there you go
you need to come on right now
eli has more passing Aris than braid
exactly right this is a random topic
yeah the guy that threw the dildo onto
the Buffalo Bills field yeah I got
arrested caught and charged damn I don't
know about legal dildo throwing my thing
is one it's become a tradition at this
point do they arrest the squid thrower
on to the NHL hockey rink for
interrupting the game you're probably
not know if he didn't throw a dildo and
if he threw a rose Josh brought this up
earlier
would he be charged now you don't think
so I don't think so like if he threw out
like a paper airplane you charging him
or is it because of what the object is I
think it's because and it's truly like
can be dangerous if it hits you okay I
guess so if there's a little substance
second do we know how it there's you
sure you sure this isn't the same guys
like this is a tradition sure yeah we
don't know I know I hope but if this guy
went to apply for a job in Buffalo and
they said do you have any criminal
history and he says yes I do I was
charged with throwing a dildo onto the
field do you think that would hurt or
help his employment in Buffalo I I don't
think it's gonna hurt it I think they're
gonna look at him if you're that guy
exactly I think he becomes like a
small-town celebrity as I got a hero
yeah I agree I agree I don't think it's
gonna hurt I think that guy would rather
go you knew I just hired screws criminal
record
I mean I'd hire wouldn't wouldn't affect
us higher I do love though that value
I'm a tradition well England plays in
Buffalo that's because they know the
cameras are gonna be there yeah can you
imagine so you've you've been around
Fred Goodell II you've been around game
directors and producers at high level in
their meeting like the Thursday before
they're like alright so we've got all
our camera set up booger you know you're
gonna come in in that first quarter
timeout make sure you hit that read and
then I just I need a I need a camera
sweep the grounds you know I want to
make sure we get if that the fact thing
comes out I want to make sure that we
get it do you think they talked about it
well I think they all talk about it like
we know it's gonna come when is it going
to come and they're not going to show it
on TV they're not gonna show it now
we're relying on Getty Images to capture
that actually they're not it's probably
against the contract for the NFL and the
other question I have about this is as
someone that's trying to make a meme or
a viral moment when is the best time to
throw set object do you do it right
after a touchdown when there's a lot of
activity and maybe try and get in that
area do you look for a TV timeout in the
second quarter do you wait for right
after Thurman Thomas is inducted until
the Ring of Honor when all the spirits
are hot
he seems like he always waits to when
the playing field is down they're like
the picture you showed me which I saw
before it looked like it was like a
timeout or something but you could see
legs of pliers towards that end zone in
the background so one a year or two ago
that was like when after the Gronk draws
like wrong dropped it and it flew right
into the pile
I remember rewinding it on film I ever
just kept sitting rewinding cuz you can
con it you could truly see it and you
could see an arm do that and you were
like right you couldn't tell like what
exact I was and I was rewinding going
forward like what guy is that oh it's
from over in the corner like this is a
pruder film right it's been very funny
for me to watch also ESPN 13 leaned into
the heart of culture not kill JFK I did
we know all right let's get to your film
where do you want to start so the big
nuggets that you have given me Bears
offense Seahawks offense Texans and am I
missing any that you sent to me late
well Jags Jags Eagles I send you the
whole game Jags Eagles
but I'm curious if there's one that
excites you the most now let's just do
it all right I want to start then bears
offense
yes and I'm gonna ask you questions
before I get to your notes yep and I
kind of want your notes to be honest cuz
I like when you don't have your notes
okay true Biscay can he throw left yeah
I don't notice I don't notice that that
does not jump out to me to my naked eye
on film now there was some throws to his
left that would that were a little
wobbly
and I wish I had now that I'm thinking
about I wish I would have paid a little
more attention to that but no I think
when I really think about he misses
equally to both sides look at it and go
man the left is really an issue for him
I went and tabulated to Rico in slumber
yeah Tariq Owen has like tripled his
touchdowns since he came on Sims and
left ko what happened his rushing yards
per carry is up his receiving yards per
catch are up a new road here in your
notes too Gabriel Miller Tirico an
explosion explosion explosion yeah they
those to me are the three guys that they
need to focus on getting the ball more
than anything
Gabriel needs to be used more in the
pass game to Rico and I think should get
more of the workload as the true runner
and I know that's you know Jordan Howard
I think a lot of them but tarik Owen is
special for me
he really is why in Westbrook compared
to Rico and to himself right and the
thing I would say too and people go oh
he's not a big back you know okay but
the one thing that Tariq Owen is
phenomenal at he does not take big hit
big hits he's so quick and shifty that
nobody ever really hits him square so I
think he can be a little bit more
durable than what people are giving him
credit for it and then yeah Miller
Anthony Miller the first another pick
this year what an adjustment on that
touchdown catch he is a really good
football player you know libri guys I
was gonna say Gabriel two or three times
a game he's a shoelace tackle away
exactly right exactly right and there
he's done a few times a game where I go
you know why did you throw the guy why
did you throw it's mirrored routes you
know I talk about mirrored routes like
the outside guys ran all this the same
routes and then there was a concept
inside and he'll you know turbo steal
throw to Bellamy and I'm just like no
look at Gabriel there he's gonna catch
that and if he makes that guy miss he's
gone just
throw it to him Alan Robinson didn't
play in this game right but in your
notes you said that two things Taylor
Gabriel is the best wide receiver on
this team he is and that Tariq Cohen is
the best player on offense yes so even
with Alan Robinson yes Alan Robinson is
not the Alan Robinson we've seen yet I
really seen before the injury and what
he was doing in Jacksonville and true
risky hasn't proven that he's like a
great back shoulder jump ball type
thrower yet so I don't think we've
gotten to see Alan Robinson at his full
capacity as a Chicago Bear you wrote
yeah the honeymoon is over
yeah he just there's a few talking about
your best career Biscay I like true
risky and I'm not giving up punch or
Biscay and I think people are still too
critical on them but I will say that the
last few weeks there's a few throws
where I just come damn you can't miss it
you can't do it just can't happen not to
saying it's gonna ruin their team but
I'm saying if they want to get in the
playoffs or beat some teams that are
equal or maybe even better than them
he's got to make those throws that game
was twenty four to ten right he hits
those throws it's 35 - exactly
okay but that game was a one-possession
game at the very end and it didn't need
to right and there's even it's like you
know other plays that you would forget
in just the minutia of the game where
you'd go man there was an out route you
got to hit that that want to keep you've
been second and two instead of you know
second and ten and then the ripple
effect of what that causes now added to
that though what do you want to go his
running is off the charts I believe that
he arguably is the best mobile
quarterback in the NFL right left oh I
you know I'm gonna pull up the team's
but he's in that discussion I mean he
doesn't want to show an Watson he's I
would think I think he beats deshaun
Watson in a race Canton
yeah he's not as physical runner bastard
he is fast like he had a few runs where
he turned the corner on Jamal Adams like
Jamal Adams that's the one where Jamal
Adams ran him out of bounds right and I
felt like I wasn't looking at Jamal and
he was just like I didn't think he was
that except I think that's exactly what
happens to a lot of the guys I do
he is a true threat as a runner you know
I've always said he's Alex Smith on
steroids right or whatever just saying
he's a more physically impressive Alex
Smith that's what he is and his running
is a real weapon and I think they need
to continue to do they had a few design
runs for him in the game and I think
they should continue to stop drafting
these guys and then not using what you
nopal he's a great runner but we never
run him well screwed then why'd you drop
him number two you gotta do it a little
he knows how to do it he knows how to
protect himself so you know use that
element a little bit more you know yeah
he's not as shifty and the natural fluid
athlete as a Shawn Watson but in a
straight race that would be something to
see that's awesome he's close the other
thing I will say that I took from this
game from your notes on the defensive
side yeah
the Jets not having a pass rusher is
defining this defense yes I mean they're
also really banged up yeah Jets are
having a ton injuries right now yeah but
it was an issue we thought before the
year and it's continued it has continued
because I think you know Todd Bowles
becomes uh you know insecure about it at
times and goes damn I don't want to let
the quarterback do it I think they
actually over blitz left go because of
that yes to where I want to just go no
your Todd Bowles you got good coverage
let Leonard wash the pocket right they
have those type of guys that can do that
so again you know sacks can be overrated
than that and and don't blitz five or
blitz six to then give you know put your
secondary in a very tough spot I think
they do overdo that a little bit the New
York Jets all right let's move to
Seahawks offense Detroit defense I
wanted you to watch this I went through
the notes only there's anything else for
that guy now I'm just type of time oh
yeah I'm just going Seahawks offense
I didn't underline anything in the notes
anymore I'm done underlined you notice
that why cuz I'm making you read them
all I had a feeling I felt like lately
you're just reading the underlying stuff
and not really spend an hour and a half
with Josh this morning I trying to come
up with a new way of getting your notes
to me in a way
so like believe me I'm thinking about I
was curious
okay Seahawks jump out 28 points in the
first half is this sustainable what
about the running offense and the first
thing I see in your notes is you
comparing David Moore to two really
great receivers in the NFL you do not
think this is um some flash in the pan
no I possibly the reason they cut
Brandon Marshall this week definitely
the reason would you compare them to who
did I compare them to third line where's
that third line David Moore bo Crabtree
and Hopkins you're right thank you yeah
see I write too many notes I can't even
think David Moore to DeAndre Hopkins he
is that type of guy where you know he
can run by you and you're not gonna sit
there and go oh that's like what he does
and that's not what the Andre Hopkins
does but of course if
you made him up he can run by you he is
enough speed but his ability to catch
the ball with people around him I've
seen enough now to go man this is real
this is not this is another guy he's six
to 220 that's big strong physical
broad-shouldered guy that is just he's
overpowering the D B's you know T's tape
or he did a good job on him in a few
times his coverage is there he just when
the balls in the air
he can't muscle up with this guy and
that's where he's good and then of
course like I said he's got enough speed
that you go damn I can't just sit on the
back shoulder he will run by you he's he
is he is he's becoming one of Russell's
favorite targets I look at Seattle on
how they're running this offense right
now
they're number one the NFL in rushing in
terms of attempts last and passing but
how they're passing I really like it
it's big shots off play action every
pass to Lockett is 25 yards down the
field right every pass to Moore is a 20
yard lob ball the only one really
catching balls underneath is Baldwin
yeah and they're not even throwing that
ball underneath that much I'm not it's
either huge chunk gains or they're
giving it off to Carson right people are
gonna look at that and go wool Russell
Wilson is the worst passing offense and
football and BoBoiBoy I would argue that
the way Russell Wilson has to play is
it's hard to play that way when you solo
I don't have visible deep oh oh my gosh
is incredible he made the throws of the
weekend his first touchdown pass running
to his left and throwing into the back
corner of the end zone right on the
money I mean that's come on that's
ridiculous and to play that way to again
it's harder sometimes than the guy who
gets to throw it 41 times because you
drop back and it's usually a big moment
to drop back or they're asking you to
make a big throw in that moment where
yeah you're not getting thrown screen
pass we're asking you to throw the 20
yard in cut over the middle of Doug
Baldwin and you got to make it and he
does it so two big notes from this game
from your notes one is about the
Seahawks offense and one is about the
Detroit defense the Seahawks offense you
wrote that you don't think that there's
a running back in the NFL that runs
harder than Chris Carson and that him
and Mike Davis are perfect for this
scheme right what are you seeing with
Chris Carson because
I'm sure that you're a little shocked
that Rashad Penny's not even getting any
reps hi I am and you know ever since he
got hurt in training camp yeah he and
those guys are like damn you want to get
hurt you want to break your finger okay
great we're taking this [ __ ] and you're
not getting back on the field
Chris Carson was the real deal he's the
real deal Chris Carson is the hardest
runner in the sport for me right now and
when I say that I mean all guys are
running hard I get that but this guy's
like it doesn't matter oh I'm about to
go you know head-to-head with the middle
linebacker my legs you're gonna keep
going and I'm gonna go forward and run
through the tackle it is phenomenal the
yards after contact the collisions he
takes and stays on his feet and
continues to run and they're made right
for man-to-man blocking they're not zone
like outside inside zone guy making one
cut and that's lying through it right
there not that tendon Coleman or what
Matty they would rather put their hand
on a guards back exactly right kind of
follow him and then I'll initiate
contact when I need exactly right that's
exactly right that's the kind of guys
they are and they're sitting there and
then they can take out great contact
balance so him and Mike Davis are
phenomenal that way and they're you know
again as we've been saying here the last
few weeks these teams are very
refreshing to watch I like this style of
football it's old-school Smash Mouth
they got some big hopes up there on the
offensive line and you believe that this
offensive line while not great and Pass
Pro little thrives and running thrives
thrives their road graders they really
are the big three the big three in the
middle I mean it's a good center the
three biggest surprises in sport right
from what we thought preseason to now
Seattle Kansas City and Caroline Wright
we had questions about all of their
offensive lines yeah and all of their
strategies and they've all and they all
had a lot of people leaving and they've
all worked out they've all worked out
the thing about Detroit's defense they
make this trade for snacks they run a
bear defense to combat this Seattle
offense and they're playing Ricky
jean-françois who weighs how much well I
mean he's like a 300 pounder he's
somewhere he's he's 313 but he's not
snacks he's not snacks he's not a Shaun
Robinson he's not - Shaun Han one common
theme I see throughout the game is when
there was a big run he was in the game
and it was him and I feel like they
caught on maybe in about the third
quarter because he started
finally be out of the game less and
that's when you start to see snacks and
a jean and hand and you believe that
what happened to Detroit on Sunday can
be fixed just by changing personnel not
totally fixed no I don't I think still
Jared Davis is a good middle linebacker
I've been Christian Jones is not playing
up to par it's a little undersized he's
undersized he doesn't make a lot of
plays he's really kind of goes unnoticed
throughout the football game and that's
not a good thing when you're a middle
linebacker you know whether you're
making tackles great or you know you
don't have to make any stats for me but
are you going up into the line of
scrimmage and taking on the lead blocker
and messing up the play in that capacity
and that's not happening either let
alone some of his run fits we're
definitely off in some of those
situations you think Detroit's defense
can turn it around because this is a
team that I got really excited about
last week I know said found their
identity yeah hey I mean you know man I
don't know what to think about them they
need Ezekiel on 'aa they really need
that extra guy because they also get
stuck in the maybe blitz a little bit
more or too many stunts you know Devon
canards up there and you know sack
leader in the NFL it's like he's got
five or six sacks something like that
but he's not really a great pass rusher
it's doing it through the Patricius
scheme I do think they can get this I
don't know if they're gonna ever be a
special unit that might not happen the
next year but with these three big
efforts in the middle there certainly
can make it harder on people all right
so the next game we had you look at was
the Texans taking on the Dolphins
because the Texans have now won five in
a row yeah now they've gotten to Mario's
Thomas yeah people have stopped talking
[ __ ] about my Super Bowl picks I wonder
why second note here Watson you said
this earlier every ball is pure pure as
hell so from the beginning of the year
till now yeah is Watson comfortable yeah
Watson is like I think this is the first
game I watched on film and said Watson
is the Watson from last year officially
again just some of the moves he made and
some of the things he did during the
game were bird yeah amazing
you also surprised me by saying that the
O line has athletes and their clique
all I heard about the Texans was how bad
their offensive line was the first few
weeks right when they started off Oh in
three right what has changed well I
think that is it just because the
Dolphins are undersized and don't have
guys well that certainly helps but I
think this is more than that this team
ran the ball in the Jacksonville Jaguars
to the week before you know I think
there is something there I think they
just found the right max match of guys
and that's why I wrote you know I think
I wrote something like they have the
right look right they got longer
athletic guys at the tackle position
with Davenport and Lam you know they're
they're they're got long arms that
they're what you wanted that tackle as
far as that's concerned
but then the inside three with Kelly
Mehdi Collette color I don't know how to
say his name column whatever it is
Callum Eddie 65 or 64 then Zac Martin's
brother Nick Martin at center and then
the Manx guy 65
those are your you know how I always
talk about how you like interior
offensive lineman to look they're
explosive they're stout they're pretty
good right and that's what I like so I
think they found the right match of guys
finally to do what they want to do you
said that you believe that Watson's
elusiveness is back yes and that Lamar
Miller's vision has been incredible it's
incredible Lamar Lamar Miller and I
don't mean just finding the hole when I
say that you know a lot of guys can find
the hole what I see that he takes to the
next level is he can read beyond the
hole and he reads the linebacker and
goes okay there's a hole here and I
could run to it but that backside
linebacker his way over committed and
he's going to be in that hole when I get
there so I'm gonna cut back and now
screw that backside linebacker who
thought he was gonna beat me to my hole
and that's where its next level stuff
and I think that's when I do a lot of
running backs not do that well no not
all of them have the ability really just
see it like that
you know the good ones do but that's
where I look at him always and just go
wow that was like especially this plate
was designed to be over here and it's
kind of there and he saw that man that
guy's way too quick over there I'm gonna
stop and replace him and get off the
field Sims with a statement towards the
NFL as we move to the Texans defense he
said I don't understand why that
dolphins went for on fourth and one on
the their first drive and he wrote this
new thing for NFL coaches just be
aggressive - [ __ ] off yes [ __ ] off I'm
so sick of that well we were just trying
to be aggressive okay oh great but I
like the aggressive well it's great you
do but you know it's you know it's just
it's like it's the new cop-out for NFL
coaches in the league you know oh we
were just trying to be aggressive and
that's exactly what the media guys got I
like aggressive they were aggressive
fans that's let's not get him at it
let's not get mad at our coach or when
he again yet tell me how aggressive went
for Mike Vrabel and the two-point
conversion in London that wasn't
aggressive that was stupid I don't know
whether way to say it you were
dominating the second half of the
football game you're the Miami Dolphins
give your team something positive with
Brock Osweiler starting the game on the
road on Thursday night against the
Houston Texas defense it's very good get
the field goal see if now kick it off
and see if they can drive on you that's
just I'm sick of this it's this whole
thing of aggressive aggressive it's it
found the cop-out way you have been in
favor of going for it on fourth downs
but you're saying go for it in smart
situation in smart situations like Mike
Zimmer same thing in this what we talked
about this start the second half
like okay I like aggressive that's
stupid
that's not aggressive that's stupid I
don't know what others way to say
aggressive is its fourth and one in the
Superbowl and I got Philly Philly that's
aggressive
that's like I've planned this out
already and played this situation out
it's not just like we're going team I
don't know are five old linemen are all
out of the game and we got back we're
going aggressive yeah okay the real
thing is what your so what I think
you're saying is when Sean Payton goes
for it on fourth and one he brings out a
wrinkle yeah he doesn't run a simple
slant that gets swatted down
Big Pun sir taste some Hill quarterback
yeah you're exactly right that's what
I'm saying exactly right it's been a
thought out aggressiveness these other
ones are just aggressive to be
aggressive because now they can't say
anything bad about me or you are still
blown away at the depth of the front
seven of the Texans yes you love the way
Kareem Jackson's playing right now hi I
got a we got to give him a little
respect
because he started the year at safety
yes and now after Koerner right and then
they got a bunch of injuries at Kevin
Johnson all that they move them back to
corner right and he's just he's a
phenomenal football player he's one of
those long tenured guys on a team that
that fan base has been rooting for him
for like eight ten years and the
national landscape just doesn't disgust
no you're exactly right nobody talks
about him he's a first-round pick from
Alabama who has been really good his
whole career and it's not sexy but he
does all the little things teams don't
go anywhere cuz it's quarterbacks of
always right and he's one of the best
tackling secondary guys in football
that's the other thing I like about him
who's the guy that got hurt they need to
be healthy oh well Jonathan Joseph yes
yeah and they need him they have to be
there one issue with that defense is
just cover guys they need him they need
him and Kareem to stay healthy cuz they
if they want to mix up man-to-man every
now and then they need it I think one
thing that you did right though is
they're not sound all the time
but because they're so unconventional it
will help them when they're facing
really good teams yeah well that's what
I want to talk about yeah because I had
the Texans go to the Super Bowl because
I think that their offense and defense
is very unconventional when you when you
play the text and you have not played a
team like them before right and I think
it's whenever I see these good offense
is the Saints the Patriots the Chiefs
they tear apart familiar scheme yeah and
unfamiliar teams kind of have an
advantage yes I totally right and Joe
Romeo's doing a good job Romeo is doing
a good job and they have all the pieces
of depth of d-line hybrid linebackers
that can do it all and then they got the
Matthews it could be an you know Tyrone
Mathieu could be a nickel it could be a
safety Kareem Jackson could be a safety
or a corner so they can do a lot of
different things you know it's like the
Baltimore Ravens there's a reason
they're number one defensive about their
unconventional the Washington Redskins
at number four
unconventional Chicago Bears with Vic
Fangio I would border him at number
seven Wade Phillips and number eight
unconventional Houston Texans number
nine unconventional they're not afraid
to change it up on a weekly basis and go
now this week we have to play this
formation this way and they haven't seen
us play it this way and it's gonna throw
this great quarterback for a loop so how
confident are you right now in the
Texans ah
watching the film are they for what what
kind of five and three five-game winning
streak team or the Texan yeah that's a
that's a good question
I mean they are certainly an improved
football team where they were from early
in the year you know so I think the
Texans have big potential I do the will
for things certainly hurt me there but
like they're part of the handful of
teams in the AFC where I go man you get
them in the playoffs and Deshawn
Watson's healthy you're not gonna feel
comfortable about that group coming to
town mmm there's no way I mean I don't
know how you could so they might not win
a lot of games pretty throughout the
year all the time but they're made for
playoff football and they got playmakers
on both sides of the ball I went through
your Jacksonville Philly notes and a lot
of it was very similar to what we
discussed on Monday but there's one
thing that I really want to focus on and
the field oh I love when you get upset
about playing conditions I mean because
I watch the game and I'll even think
about it but like you know what people
get upset about yeah how dare the LA
Coliseum have a USC logo bleeding
through to a rams logo who cares it
doesn't impact anything there's a game
in London where the field is torn up and
your theory about five foot eight 150
pound a sleet's on a field compared to
Fletcher Cox is perfect I mean it's what
it is and la is embarrassing too I mean
there was a college game on that field
the night before why our college
athletes playing on better fields and
pro NFL athlete players why is the
athlete from Ohio State or the
University of Florida or Georgia or
Alabama playing on a better field and a
weekly basis than guys who are making
millions of dollars and it's their job
to support the Bama because of the ruse
of college education and the hundreds of
thousands of dollars that come in from
tens of thousands of kids that are not
used on education they're used on field
well okay sure that instead of the
private and office of an owner
yeah the private pockets of the owner
which then he tries to get more money
and goes yeah hey college team rent out
my stadium so I could screw over some
more money from the people of this area
but it wasn't that it was a bad field
huh yeah it's just it's
soon as it turned on the film was the
first thing I see I just go gay what do
you see on the film that makes you go
that field sucks just choppiness
everywhere it's not ever flying in there
flying you could tell before it even
they start the game I mean if I pulled
it up you just go yeah it just doesn't
look pretty when you see turf going up
yeah how does that impact the game you
see it with like you're 34 Bradley or
MacDougall whatever Dexter Dexter module
slip in a few times or big guys who are
trying to hold their ground and their
feet give out underneath them it's
things like that and I just go it's a
joke I mean that's another reason like
the old pleasure of safety but we're not
gonna give you a solid footing they
manchester city played on that field
like that all day what was that like all
I went on Twitter and I was like let me
just see people were freaking out it's
embarrassing that to play on this there
was just after the Eagles and jaguars
which is like a top five like doggoned
all right the the pitch just had a big
brown line right down the middle of the
pitch yeah and Manchester City fans were
going nuts that they had to play on the
I bet they were yeah welcome to the NFL
Manchester City okay because these guys
got to do it all the time there ugh
they're crazed that they're five nine
hundred and forty pound Englishman has
to do it but they're not crazed that
coleus Campbell at six eight three
twenty he's doing it and they're like
who cares you're big and strong like
yeah it's just unbelievable Sims there's
a very special thing happening tomorrow
night and this is we're gonna in the
podcast dude
Carson Wentz was so good in that game I
know you wrote there like seven well you
you said that on Monday - yeah and he
was incredible and that Cam Newton
couldn't do these things and nobody like
him and cam like those are the kind of
guys like just with the people around
them and the throws and that's just
again it goes back to our whole like
size is a skill type of thing at the
quarterback position yeah he's just a
minute dude come on catches his own pass
and gets a first down that was awesome
come on got people around you know you
talked about ducking coleus Campbell I
don't think anyone has a stronger
looking base than Carson Wentz it is I
think when Carson wants to eat that foot
out it's it's awesome I love that guy
he's got no style at alpha it was awful
yeah but something specials tomorrow
night at Thursday night tonight
when you listen to this podcast your
best friend is taking on your former
coach I know I the game itself not
interested yeah CJ Beathard is probably
not gonna pay play I might put a lot of
money on the Raiders tomorrow night in
our bets I just don't see the Raiders at
least can score I would think I don't
know how the nine I mean unless we know
your spreads yeah I don't want to know
either but what do you think this is
like for Kyle taking on his former coach
- yeah cuz he was an assistant I think
it's like it's always personal dude
agreed I mean personal I mean baby you
want to beat the guy just like we talked
about with McVeigh and Curtin but to me
it goes and not jump because they're
fighting in the same city this is
bragging rights it's it's all of that
and they don't sink and the loser is
they're really bad exactly you know
because if the Raiders lose the Niners
can go we're not we're better than the
Raiders yeah yeah I don't know I still
can't believe the 49ers lost
I heard someone says at the office
yesterday Arizona Cardinals twice and
they were up 15 or they were up 13 3 for
both of these teams at this point in the
season a win is a loss and a loss is a
win because you're saying for draft
bears yeah I disagree for team morale
San Francisco needs to continue to learn
how to win football yes that would be my
thing they have to continue to instill
this culture they don't know how to do
it you know throughout so that's
something that still has to be I'm still
see an ORAC Armstead celebrating as
they're the other teams going to drive
to win I'm like Eric I don't I don't
know this right now winning culture is
not instilled there yet and all I think
I would push against that which I mean
you know you're not off there but at the
same time the Niners aren't looking for
a quarterback and I would be I don't
know I never put it back screwed and
Gruden could he could draft the kid from
working with the first pick of the draft
I don't know who the hell knows with
John in that department he might drop
the kid from Auburn keep Derek Carr and
also signed Joe Flacco I mean that's
what Gruden can do who the [ __ ] knows I
don't know yeah I feel like I feel like
the Niners need to win this more the
Raiders feel like cellars where the
Niners are like in a holding pattern
because the quarterback is hurt yeah but
do you think either of them whip out
some crazy offense
plays because beyond the score of the
game I'm gonna be watching going who has
the more creative offense because this
is former wunderkind versus current
wonder kyle has the more creative
offense I'll just tell you I think
John's gonna whip out some I know
primetime Thursday night Troy Aikman on
the call it's not Gruden's DNA to do
trick plays it really is not just wants
to beat you with his he just wants to
beat you with his stuff now maybe this
week draws it out of him he is getting
into that desperation mode the last time
I remember him pulling a trick play it
was the game I lost my spleen we did the
flea flicker in that game and we
completed it but yes it was but we were
also Owen too and we were like damn we
need to play because you're doing very
good so you know I wouldn't shock me but
it's just not normal for him to do that
time I think we're gonna get a
high-scoring game I would think so I
mean if the nine well the Niners are but
there's a quarterback I don't I don't
know what to expect with him should have
been mad Sims efficient podcast today
way to go felt good good job team yeah
all right I'll check out Simpson left go
the show where of course we had Brian
Westbrook and I pranked Simms so you
have to check that out and then we're
gonna do our betting show where one of
us is winning the black one of us have
you bet and also I can teach you how one
of our listeners turn three dollars into
a hundred into $400 in just two weeks
I'll explain on the betting show since
there's no idea what I'm talking about
for sim CSAT homies federic would say
good evening everybody and for the lef
koe man we will holla holla holla at you
later
be well
[Music]